I'll give you guys something to work  with we'll give you like hey guys I'm  Charlize Theron and these are my  favorite films as of this moment three  billboards in Epping Missouri just  because I just saw it and it's [ __ ]  amazing and Fran McDorman is gone I'm  glad you got your priorities straight  I'll say that for you trains planes and  automobiles classic you cannot go wrong  with that film and I've seen it probably  150 times and it just gets better I love  me some can go into a black and white  days of wine and roses classic track  lemon doing drama and he's really  incredible playing a drunk jaws come on  don't have to say you're gonna need a  bigger potion this is a boring one cuz  they say it all the time splash it's a  great film  they forced my kids to watch it this  Christmas